die Wut kommt am frühen Morgen mit
hunderten PS nach Berlin direkt zum
Brandenburger Tor so viele Traktoren
können ein politisches Beben verursachen
wenn das wirklich kommt Subvention Weg
für Agrardiesel oben drauf noch eine KFZ
Steuer für landwirtschaftliche Fahrzeuge
dann gibt es für diese Bauern nur ein
Urteil eure Politik ist unser
Tod ist jetzt der Tropfen zu viel
gewesen und das Fass ist nicht nur
übergelaufen sondern ist geborsten für
die junge Generation die jetzt
Landwirtschaft betreiben will in den
nächsten Jahrzehnten das den gerade die
Perspektive und die Zukunft genommen
wird der bauernpräsident wütet wir
nehmen das nicht hin und zu viel ist zu
viel entweder Wechsel die Regierung
ihren g oder und das habe ich schon in
der Rede gesagt muss es einen
Regierungswechsel geben östem verspricht
sich bei der eigenen Regierung stark zu
machen für für die Bauern Solidarität
und Machtlosigkeit mir ist sehr klar und
das war ja gerade auch zu hören und zu
sehen und vielleicht auch zu riechen was
diese Entscheidung Folgen haben kann
deshalb Kämpfe im Kabinett dafür dass es
in dieser herte nicht
komm man glaubt es mir nicht die
Opposition reih sich heute nicht
zufällig
ein zi Jahre jetzt so weitermachen das
sieht man hier die Stimmung ist
polarisiert ich ver die B dieehen mit
Rücken zurand den Sprecher der
Bundesregierung ganz in der Nähe und
scheinbar in einer anderen Welt lassen
die Proteste recht unbeeindruckt die
allgemeine Einigung und auch die
grundsätzliche Stoßrichtung bleiben und
jetzt muss man in den einzelnen
Maßnahmen sehen aber da sehe ich jetzt
wenig
änderungswillen innerhalb der
Bundesregierung doch änderungswille
scheint vorhanden habbeck will zwar das
Gesamtpaket nicht wieder aufschnüren
aber man müsse über nativen nachdenken
Lindner will das auch und die SPD ebenso
die auch die Pendlerpauschale anheben
will um künftig höhere Spritpreise
abzufedern das sind Mehrbelastung den
Pendlerin und Pendler gerade im
ländlichen Raum nicht aus dem Weg gehen
können und deswegen ist hier ein
Ausgleich aus unserer Sicht angezeigt
zurück zur Wut und den Bauern wenn die
Regierung ihre Sparpläne nicht komplett
streicht kommen sie Anfang Januar wieder
das ist eine Drohung mit hunderten
pS Ja und der der gegen die komplette
Streichung der Subventionen aber für
eine Überarbeitung war ist mir jetzt aus
Berlin zugeschaltet der
Landwirtschaftsminister von den Grünen
schönen guten Abend J östemer guten
Abend Frau harali Herr Minister wird
denn die geplante Streichung der
Agrarsubventionen rückgängig gemacht
also schauen Sie es ist doch klar dass
sich niemand dem schwarzwang entziehen
kann der kommt durch das Urteil aus
Karlsruhe das das gilt auch für mein
Haus das ist mir schon klar aber was
jetzt beschlossen wurde das ist eben das
nicht nur die KFZ Steuerbefreiung
sondern auch das dieselprivileg
wegfallen soll damit quasi eine
Milliarde nur die Landwirte die
Landwirte leisten ihren Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz die Landwirtschaft hat ihre
Klimaziele erreicht das kann man jetzt
nicht von allen Sektoren sagen und das
ist etwas was viele Landwirte vor den
Kopf stößt weil sie sagen das ist nicht
gerecht beim Agrardiesel kommt dazu es
gibt ja gar kein Ersatz die schweren
landm inen lassen sich nicht anders
betanken also ich kann ihn ja gar keine
Alternative anbieten und da muss man
schon den zor der Landwirte auch
verstehen fen wir Gespräch und finden
hofentlich Lösung fr aber die Frage war
ja wird das wieder rückgängig gemacht
sie haben jetzt viele Argumente genannt
gute Argumente sicherlich auch aus Sicht
der Landwirtschaft aber wird das
rückgängig gemacht ich bin um Nachsicht
dass ich das nicht im heute journal
jetzt klären kann aber wir führen
Gespräche ich habe das ganze Wochenende
damit verbracht ich bin auch dem
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
dankbar dass er angekündigt hat dass man
sich das noch mal anschaut robert habik
hat sie jetzt ähnlich geäußert wir
führen diese Gespräche mit dem Ziel dass
es so nicht kommen kann das ist zu viel
aber die Argumente die sie jetzt gerade
auch schon genannt haben die die Bauern
heute auch noch mal formuliert haben die
sind ja alle samt nicht wirklich neu
wieso fängt jetzt das überlegen an und
nicht eigentlich innerhalb dieser vier
fast vier Wochen wo Scholz Harbeck und
Lindner verhandelt haben na weil es auch
nicht ganz einfach ist kurzfristig 17
Milliarden Euro zu mobilisieren und so
wie ich gute Argumente haben haben
natürlich auch andere gute Argumente in
ihren Bereichen worum es mir geht es
einfach noch mal deutlich zu machen die
Landwirtschaft ist bereits zur
Veränderung die Landwirtschaft weiß da
gibt's Klimawandel es gibt Erwartungen
aus der Verbraucherschutz
Verbrauchersicht was Tierschutz angeht
aber das alles geht nur wenn man es mit
der Landwirtschaft macht nicht gegen die
Landwirtschaft und die hat die zwei
Jahre in den ich Minister bin gut
mitgemacht gut
begleitet jetzt überziehen wir ist die
Lobby nur stark genug dann knickt die
Ampel ein so könnte man das ja fast
verstehen ich glaube nicht dass es hier
um Lobby geht das also wenn man eins in
der Politik lernen muss dann ist es das
echte klagen vom falschen klagen und zu
unterscheiden das hier ist kein falsches
klagen das ist echtes klagen hier geht's
wirklich um Existenzsorgen hier geht's
um Hof nachfolgen und jetzt könnte man
sagen wie viel Bauern gibt's aber es
geht hier nicht nur um die Bauern es
geht um die ländlichen Räume es geht um
das Verhältnis stadtland und da mache
ich mir große Sorgen dass uns da was
wegbricht das Rechtspopulist das
übernehmen das kann in niemandes
Interesse sein weder im Interesse der
Regierung noch im Interesse der
demokratischen Opposition robert habbeck
hatte ja nach dem Kompromiss gesagt die
Ampel ist handlungsfähig und trägt die
Beschlüsse gemeinsam offenbar ja dann
jetzt doch nicht denn jetzt wird wieder
gestritten und alles wird wieder in
Frage gestellt das ist doch keine
verlässliche und auch keine
vertrauenswürdige Politik die sie da
machen na ja gerade weil ich
Verlässlichkeit gerade weil ich
Planungssicherheit möchte für den
Bereich für den ich zuständig bin geht's
natürlich drum dass die Landwirte auch
sich drauf einstellen können müssen und
eine solche Maßnahme gleich zwei an der
Zahl von heute auf morgen das ist glaube
ich da haben wir überzogen und es ist
glaube ich keine Schande wenn man auch
ehrlich zugibt vielleicht haben wir da
an der Stelle nicht genau genzogen sind
sie auch gefragt worden oder hat der
Wirtschaftsminister und der
Finanzminister und der Kanzler überzogen
nein die drei haben sie es nicht einfach
gemacht sie müssen den Auftrag des
Verfassungsgerichtes umsetzen und ich
stehe auch hinter Pflicht meinen Beitrag
dazu zu leisten noch mal demenziehe ich
mich nicht und wenn ich jetzt sage
zumindest eine der beiden Maßnahmen muss
zurückgenommen werden dann stehe ich
jetzt auch vor der Aufgabe damit
verbringe ich gerade meine Zeit zu
schauen wo wir das Geld herbekommen sagt
der Agrarminister chem Ö mir vielen
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Zeit alles Gute
gerne ich danke Ihnen